asked me i looked i i i decided to watch
one and then i said i liked it oh thank
you my physicist i knew i think but i
appreciate the
the width of your the the
um of your questions and uh and the fact
that you went uh very detailed but you
know
a good uh
uh
um
uh middle ground sort of so you you seem
to know what you were talking about yeah
i seem to i'm great pretending
so professor why don't you explain your
relational view your interpretation of
quantum mechanics
uh wonderful thank you kurt for for
having me here uh first of all please
don't call me professor everybody calls
me carol and that's how i feel uh
comfortable with
right so relational quantum mechanics is
uh um the way i think
it's uh i think it's more interesting to
try to understand quantum mechanics
there are as you know kurt there are a
number of uh interpretations of quantum
mechanics out there
i find them all interesting um i think
that none of them it's wrong um i think
they're all each one
is right uh
but each one has a cost a price to pay
and the question is uh are we ready to
pay this price is it useful to pay this
price to to go ahead and better
understand the world
and uh
i think the the relationship quantum
mechanics which i'm going to describe in
a moment uh also have a price like
everything
a philosophical price okay
uh but i think it's the best price to
pace if we if we buy that then we
understand the world better
um
the
the mystery of quantum mechanics can be
can be expressed in different manners um
one way of of presenting it is that what
the what the theory gives us
is what we see when we look when we see
when we measure it give predictions for
measurement
uh and that's the way it's it's uh it's
formulated in in textbooks uh
the textbook quantum mechanic talks
about the observer you talk about the
measurement apparatus they talk about uh
um
about the outcome of the of the
measurement
now
this is okay if you want to use it in
fact a lot of people use quantum
mechanics in these terms and uh very
happy period there's no no question
after that but of course it's not okay
uh if we
after we've realized quantum mechanics
are 100 years old after we've realized
that uh uh quantum mechanics is actually
the best thing we have for everything
for galaxies for star for for
structure for nature in the universe for
what happened inside the sun
so it it's how we want to think about
the world uh at the
most fundamental physical level that we
have access today
and then
what the hell is an apparatus
and an observer doing into that there
are no observers in the sun or or in the
early universe when star formed
so something is missing obviously in the
standard textbook presentation of
quantum mechanics which is who is
observed uh
what what is a major what is a
measurement
and one way of saying that is that uh in
the in the in the standard presentation
quantum mechanic there are two
postulates two assumptions
which appear to be contradictory to one
another one is that
if you don't look you have a quantum
system it evolves in a way which is
described by the schrodinger equation by
unitary evolution
things change
if you look
there is a different postulate which is
a projection postulate that says that
the state does not evolve schrodinger
evolution but it just jumps
um and the visual way of viewing this is
that
a particle uh like an electron is
described like a wave
that satisfies the schrading equation so
wave diffuses in space when you look at
it you see in a point so the wave
collapses in a point and when does it
collapses when there's a measurement
and when is a measurement when observer
and parameters
measure it
but
there are no observers a paratha inside
the sun no observer a paratha inside
a
distant galaxy or
or in all the cases we use quantum
mechanics so that's the problem
and
there are
many solutions on the table um some
people think that uh you know
it's always waves so the particle never
goes to a point and the reality will
happen is that we are self waves and we
split in many different copies of
ourselves this is a main world
interpretation
and others
now the relational
and i'll finally come to you to your
question the relationship interpretation
is idea that we can make sense of that
by simply thinking
that what happens between the particle
and the observer
the particle in the measurement parata
is generic and it's not because of
special property of the server or the
measuring apparatus just what happened
between any
system in any other system
in the universe
so every time two systems we describe
the world uh by splitting it in systems
physical systems like the sun like a
particle a molecule
the earth you me these are all systems
from the perspective of physicists
every time two of these interact so
exchange something
uh
one so to say measure the other
so if this is a particle
when it interact with me the particle
collapses in a point has a position
okay
but
this is not true
this is only true the posit particles of
pollution only with respect to this
system not with respect to the rest of
the universe
so if somebody else in the universe uh
it's uh uh
it's uh it's later interacting with a
particle and this observer here
doesn't have to take into account this
collapse
so the collapse and the unit of
evolution are always both true
good postulate for describing what
happened
in the universe you just refer
to different
systems
the ones which are directly interacting
what is relevant is a projected
postulate the ones which are not
involved interacting which still may
have an interesting of you know
computing what's going to happen next in
the interaction to them
um
for them is relevant the unitary
evolution postulate
so
the
this is it i mean this solves completely
the quantum mechanical problems because
uh
uh now we know what is a what is a
system and now what is an observer
nothing special all systems are the
systems all system help server
and now we know when to use one posture
than the other
uh
the price to pay is that
the particle being in a position
it's only relative to the system it has
interacted with not relevant to
something else with respect to something
else is still spread around still a wave
everywhere
so
all the variable taken values always
relative relative to a system
so this means
that when we describe the world
uh we describe the world uh
giving values to variable i means
microphone is here that color on the
screen is red
you know the sun is there these are all
variables that
values the variables take
the color the position
etc
these if you if you buy the relational
interpretation of quantum mechanics they
are not absolute
properties of a system their property of
the system with respect to me or with
respect to this chair not me as a human
being
me as a physical system
so that's a religion relational because
the suggestion here is don't think
at reality
as
systems with properties
rather
think of reality
as a system that has properties where
they interact with something else only
when they interact with something else
and relatively to this is something else
that's a solution a possible solution of
the quantum mechanic
puzzle
the cost of this is accepting
this weakened realism so to say the
world is not made by a substance with
properties
it's made by interacting pieces
uh
and the pieces have properties only with
interact
okay so firstly let's remove the word
observer and say interaction because
observer seems to imply in people's mind
a human being essentially or something
conscious
okay exactly
so there's that and then
what i'm wondering is
let's say so i have a bedroom here and i
don't know what's going on pretend it's
much farther away and i haven't
interacted with it something's going on
in that bedroom now to those people who
are interacting in this bedroom right
now they're
their properties are defined they're
they've collapsed their wave function in
a sense okay that's good is there and
let's say they've come up with some
value and that says
it could be a or b and they've come up
with value a for some like the heads
heads on a coin now is there a reason
that necessarily if i was to interact
with them that it consistently comes up
with the same answer
or is that not necessarily the case
um
good
uh
yes
there is a reason
and uh uh
um
but but one has
has to be careful in in formulating
things properly
properly
namely
um
if you
uh
let's see exactly what what it means
uh suppose you yourself measure that
property and and you found a
and then you interact with them
and ask them hey what have you seen
then for sure
you would get something consistent
this is the precise meaning of
seeing the same thing
in other words
you can compare what
what you have seen and what the
the people in the room have
seen
by talking to them or by asking them or
by measuring them
but this interaction is quite mechanical
so
uh this interaction is uh itself a
physical interaction not outside physics
you cannot out go outside the world and
somehow
cheat physics circumvent and say oh
physics is not looking let me ask you
what you've seen that's you cannot do
that's the point
so um
yes there is consistency and why i am so
careful in saying that
because uh quantum mechanics is tricky
as you know if you measure the position
of a particle then you measure the
momentum you destroy
the information about the position
immediately after you measure the
position again it's not the previous one
so but measure the momentum the position
is affected
so you have to be careful because if you
ask these people a question which is
like the momentum toward the position
you might be destroying
uh
some
of the
uh
of the properties
and it might be
therefore uh
neither true nor false that the value um
is a
like when you
when you do a double slit interference
if you measure the interference you
cannot ask anymore which way the
particle has gone through which slit the
particle has gone to so by asking when
there is no answer to the one to the
other one
so
the point is that when you when you
compare what two different observables
have seen you have to be careful that
there are this interference effects
that might create
uh
a
a different
uh
my in my block the possibility of
identifying exactly what what the two
have seen so as long as you keep asking
questions
uh
which are not like position moment that
don't destroy previous information
everything is consistent every observer
sees the same world
you